une des plus jolies combinaisons de
maths de l'histoire des échecs dans une
très vieille partie qui date de la fin
du 19e siècle entre vacaroni et masochi
ici les Blancs ont l'air plutôt mal en
point puisque leur roi est sous la
menace d'un échec et mat et on a
l'impression que leur attaque patine un
peu toutes les pièces noires ont l'air
de parfaitement défendre à première vue
il y a pas d'échec qui marche et
pourtant il y a un superbe combinaison
de maths si vous les trouvez pas
vous-même je vous laisse mettre pause
une seconde sinon voici la solution Tom
GK on sacrifié la dame le fouet obligé
de la capturer et derrière un deuxième
sacrifice somptueux tout point H6 elle
est défendue par le fou on dévie le pion
et le fou blanc vient délivrer un mat de
modèle les deux fous contrôlent toutes
les diagonales et le Renoir est cloué au
pylori